d'intrigue, de culpabilité inter-religieuse et de honte.
Mais j'étais totalement immergée dans ce monde
rempli de monde,
puis j'ai été à l'école des Nations-Unies
et ça a complètement -
J'ai commencé a développer ces voix
et ces gens,
tous inspirés par d'autres personnes que je connais bien,
par exemple, en les interprétant,
j'essaie vraiment de les habiter.
Par exemple,
je ne parle pas vraiment comme ça
mais c'est une de mes connaissances.
Je ferai vivre quelques-uns de mes amis -
j'aime penser qu'ils sont mes amis -
sur cette scène, avec à l'esprit
que le présent est le nouveau futur,
d'une façon métaphysique,
parce que j'y ai pensé et, en ce qui me concerne, le futur,
ce qui est si effrayant,
c'est que je ne sais pas ce qui s'en vient.
Je ne sais pas si c'est vrai pour les autres,
mais cette notion de penser que
notre façon de comprendre le futur
et prédire ses résultats,
pour moi, c'est terrifiant de ne pas savoir ce qui s'en vient.
L'idée qu'il y a des questions
que je n'ai jamais vues
auxquelles mes personnages vont répondre.
Certains de ceux-ci sont avec moi depuis longtemps,
certains n'ont même pas de nom.
Je ne sais pas ce qui va arriver.
Je ne sais pas ce qui vient,
je ne peux que me rappeler
que j'ai dit à Chris que j'allais improviser
et maintenant que je suis ici, je me sens comme
dans les rêves on n'a pas de pantalon,
et je suppose que je vais
improviser à poil.
Ceci dit, voyons qui viendra.
Pouvons-nous avoir la première question ?
« Avez vous des migraines
à cause de la puce implantée dans votre cerveau ? »
D'accord.
Bon.
Premièrement, je dirais
que j'espère que vous m'entendez bien.
Je m’appelle Lorraine Levine
et l'idée de la puce implantée dans mon cerveau,
honnêtement, juste mettre mes lunettes me rappelle
que j'ai de la chance de ne pas porter de lunettes Google.
Rien contre eux. Je suis contente que vous les aimez
mais à mon âge,
mettre mes lunettes normales, à moi,
me donne déjà trop d'information.
Comprenez-vous ce que je dis ?
Je n'ai pas besoin de plus. Je ne veux pas savoir.
C'est tout. C'est assez.
Je vous aime tous, vous êtes merveilleux.
C'est génial d'être ici avec de grands « machers »
encore cette année. Mouah!
Question suivante. (Applaudissements)
Suivante, s'il vous plaît.
« Est-ce que les sorties sont ennuyeuses,
maintenant que les humains se reproduisent sans sexe ? »
Qui avons-nous ?
Allo, hum, okay, salut tout le monde.
Je m’appelle Nereida.
Je veux juste dire tout d'abord
que les sorties ne sont jamais ennuyeuses.
Mais, euh, je suis très excitée d'être ici en ce moment,
alors j'essaie seulement de me rappeler que,
vous savez, la raison d'être ici et tout,
je veux dire, essayer de vous répondre est très excitant.
Mais aussi, je dois avouer
que TED est une expérience incroyable
en ce moment, genre, je veux juste dire, genre maintenant,
Isabel Allende. Isabel Allende !
Okay, peut-être que ça ne veut pas dire ce que ça veut dire,
je veux dire, bien sûr que ça veut dire quelque chose pour vous,
mais pour moi, c'est genre, un autre niveau, okay?
Je suis latino et j'apprécie vraiment le fait
qu'il y a des modèles ici que je peux vraiment.
je ne sais pas, j'ai juste besoin de le dire.
C'est incroyable, quelques fois quand je suis nerveuse et tout,
j'ai besoin de dire, genre, quelques affirmations
qui peuvent m'aider.
D'habitude, J'essaie d'utiliser trois petits mots
qui me font toujours sentir mieux :
Sotomayor, Sotomayor, Sotomayor. (Rires)
Ça m'aide à garder les pieds sur terre.
Je peux utiliser Allende, Allende, Allende,
et, vous savez, il faut que je le dise, genre,
c'est vraiment super d'être ici, et je savais qu'on allait avoir toutes ces questions
j'étais super nerveuse et je me disais, genre, oh mon Dieu, oh mon Dieu
et me le rappelant, parce que j'ai eu, genre, de mauvaises,
surtout depuis la dernière fois qu'on était ici, à TED,
c'était, comme, incroyable
et puis juste après ça, comme,
tellement de choses incroyables se sont passées,
on a fini par se produire à la Maison Blanche.
Ça c'était, genre, super,
et je suis là-bas,
et j'étais genre, je dois pas dire « Oh mon Dieu ! »
Je dois pas dire « Oh mon Dieu ! »
Et je n'ai fait que dire « Oh mon Dieu ! ».
Et, tu sais, je m'disais des choses du genre,
le président Obama est venu sur le même podium,
et je suis plantée là à dire « Oh mon Dieu ! »
C'est comme la séparation de l’État et de l’Église.
J'arrivais pas à réfléchir.
C'était vraiment trop.
Alors, je pense que je me suis perdue.
Mais ce que je veux dire, c'est que les rancards pour moi,
en ce qui me concerne,
la façon que vous vous reproduisez, tant que vous prenez votre pied
et que c'est avec un autre asexué consentant - je sais pas.
Vous savez où je veux en venir.
Okay, ciao, merci.
Question suivante. (Applaudissements)
Quelles sont vos 5 chansons favorites?
Bien, premièrement, je vais dire,
vous savez, je suis le seul mec en ce moment.
Mon nom est Rashid
et je n'ai jamais été à TED avant,
tu sais c'que je veux dire.
Je crois que Sarah Jones ne voulait pas que je vienne la dernière fois.
J'sais pas pourquoi, tu piges.
Je suis, comme, le mec idéal pour TED.
Tu piges.
Primo, je suis dans le Hip Hop, tu captes.
Je sais que certains de vous ne sont pas vraiment
très dans cette musique,
mais la première chose que tu dois savoir,
tu sais, je suis dans le hip hop.
C'est moi qui tiens le micro
dans la posture officielle MC.
Tu peux voir là, cette position.
C'est comme ça que ça se tient.
alors je te donne ta petite leçon là.
Mais quand Sarah Jones m'a dit que j'allais venir ici,
j'étais comme, salope, tu captes
TED c'est bat. J'ai de la came,
tu vois ce que je veux dire, du shit plein les poches,
mais elle était comme, ouais.
il faut qu'on réponde à des questions genre de partout.
C'est quoi ce bordel ?
tu vois ce que je veux dire, mets-toi debout ici
et réponds aux questions ?
Je ne veux pas.
C'est comme une fouille intellectuelle.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire? (Rires)
je veux pas rester debout, comme ça
et être interrogé.
J'essaie de laisser ça derrière moi
a New York, tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Il faut que je te dise mes 5 chansons top en ce moment
de mes catalogues personnels,
tu comprends ?
Si tu veux en savoir plus,
tu vois,
on peut parler de l'anti-piratage et tout,
mais en ce qui me concerne,
je crois à la créativité commune,
et je pense que c'est important pour nous, tu sais,
il faut que ce soit durable et tout.
Et à mon avis,
je veux dire tout ça là,
cet environnement, je veux durer ici
vous savez ce que je veux dire !
Je veux juste dire, si vous êtes intéressés
il faut que vous fassiez du bruit pour que je présente les cinq chansons du top
vous savez ?
OK ! Dans le futur ou le présent, ouais !
Profitez bien du reste !
Question suivante.
Qu'est-ce qu'on a là ?
« Combien de vos organes ont été imprimés en 3D ? »
(Rires)
Eh bien je dois dire que je ne sais pas tellement
combien de mes organes
ont été imprimés en 3D en réalité,
mais je peux vous dire que c'est tellement épanouissant pour moi
de penser un peu à ce concept du futur
et que partout dans le monde,
les parents disent à leurs jeunes enfants :
« S'il te plaît, tu dois manger ça, tu sais.
J'ai travaillé dur sur une imprimante 3D chaude toute la journée
pour que tu puisses manger ce repas. »
Vous savez ce genre de choses.
Mais, bien sûr, maintenant que nous avons changé
depuis le sud mondial, il y a cette sorte de décalage
ce changement de perspective qui prend place autour du, euh...
Vous savez, on ne peut pas juste leur dire :
« Il y a des enfants qui meurent de faim. »
Eh bien c'est le futur.
Mais plus personne ne meurt de faim à présent, grâce à Dieu.
Mais comme vous pouvez le voir, j'ai en quelque sorte cet optimisme.
Et j'espère bien que nous pourrons continuer
à imprimer en 3D disons,
bien, disons que j'aime à penser que
même dans le futur, nous aurons la publication
de, vous savez, tous les aliments qui peuvent être imprimés.
Mais que tout le monde ici en profite s'il vous plaît,
et encore une fois, je pense que vous donnez
une fête géniale ici, à TED.
Merci.
Question suivante. (Applaudissements)
Hum, qu'est-ce qui a changé ? Qu'est-ce qui a changé.. Ok, c'est genre
Je, je vais devoir y réfléchir,
Qu'est-ce qui a changé maintenant que les femmes dirigent le monde ?
Premièrement,
Vraiment, je veux juste dire,
je m'appelle Bella,
je veux juste m'identifier
que, genre, en tant que féministe,
je, genre, je trouve que franchement, genre,
vous savez, parce que je suis née dans les années 1990
et, genre, il y avait beaucoup de femmes qui étaient
très loin du féminisme
Peut-être qu'elles ne comprenaient pas que, genre,
Une féministe comme moi, genre,
Je pense qu'il n'est pas nécessaire d'avoir
un certain type de voix,
ou une certaine manière de se présenter
pour être féministe.
Car je pense que le féminisme peut être très sensuel.
Je pense en réalité que c'est même vraiment vital et important.
Genre, la citation que je porte sur mon t-shirt vient de
Gloria Steinem.
Et, genre, je m'appelle Bella d'après Bella Abzug,
qui est, genre, évidemment une très grande féministe dans l'histoire.
Et genre, je pense juste que ces femmes, genre
représentent vraiment le fait que, genre,
on peut être vitales, et genre, géniales
genre gé-niales!
Et on n'est pas obligé de porter, genre,
un caftan Eileen Fisher
juste pour, genre, prouver que l'on est féministe.
Genre, pas qu'il y ait quoi que ce soit de mal à porter ça,
mais ma mère, elle est genre,
genre, pourquoi portes-tu des pantalons comme ça, genre
pourquoi tu objectifies ton corps ? J'aime mes pantalons !
C'est comme, j'aime ma voix !
Genre, elle dit genre, « pourquoi faut-il toujours que tu parles comme... »
« que je parle comme quoi? » Genre, je m'exprime
Et je pense que nous devons genre,
nous adresser à, genre, pas seulement aux
différentes générations de féministes
mais aussi à portée de voix, genre,
pour pouvoir genre, que l'on
parce que sinon c'est juste, genre,
«stricticule» dans le féminisme,
c'est juste un mot, genre, que j'ai inventé,
qui veut dire genre, tellement strict que c'en est ridicule.
Alors, c'est mon sentiment à propos de tout ça.
Vous êtes géniaux en passant.
Ok, question suivante.
(Applaudissements)
«On a découvert un traitement pour le cancer mais pas pour la chauveté? qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire ?»
Ouais, vous savez quoi,
eh bien je m’appelle Joseph Mancuso.
Dans un premier temps, je voulais dire que j'apprécie le fait que
TED soit un public qui se tient bien de manière générale,
un groupe bien sage.
Euh, et vous voyez, je dois simplement dire que
toute cette histoire de chauveté...
vous savez, c'est ça le hic.
Tant que la femme, c'est comme ça chez moi;
parce qu'on vit dans un monde moderne
faites ce que vous voulez, je n'ai aucun problème avec qui que ce soit
Profitez et amusez-vous, LGBTQLMNOP. C'est bon ?
Mais, vous voyez, en ce qui me concerne,
l'attirance,
pour les femmes, ce n'est pas
aussi important qu'on le croit
à propos de... vous savez...
je veux dire, je me souviens d'avoir entendu une femme,
elle adorait son mari, c'était adorable,
C'est une fille assez jeune en fait, vous savez ?
Et l'homme en question était plus vieux.
Et euh, vous savez, elle disait qu'elle l'aimerait
même s'il se dégarnissait un peu
ou s'il devenait carrément chauve comme un genou.
En ce qui me concerne, c'est l'amour qui compte.
J'ai raison ou j'ai raison ?
Alors c'est tout, c'est tout, c'est tout !
J'ai plus rien à dire.
Tenez-vous à carreau.
Bien, question suivante.
« Avez-vous déjà goûté de la viande qui n'ait pas été cultivée en laboratoire ? »
Euh, eh bien, je,
j'aimerais commencer en disant
que c'est une expérience très difficile
pour une sino-américaine.
Je ne sais pas comment comment m'appeler maintenant
car j'ai vraiment mon identité chinoise
mais mes enfants, eux sont américo-chinois,
mais c'est difficile pour moi d'essayer de m'exprimer
devant un public, devant des gens comme ça.
Mais, si je devais donner mon avis sur la viande,
je pense d'abord que la chose la plus importante à dire
est que nous ne sommes pas obligés d'avoir de la nourriture parfaite,
mais peut-être que ça peut aussi ne pas être du poison.
Peut-être que l'on peut avoir des avis mitigés pour ça.
Mais je vais continuer à examiner cette idée
et je ferai un rapport peut-être l'année prochaine.
Suivante.
Suivante, suivante (applaudissements)
«Existera-t-il un jour un monde post-racial ? »
Euh, euh, merci de me recevoir.
Je m'appelle Gary Tête-de-Belette, je euh, amusez-vous avec ça.
Je fais parti de la nation des Pieds-Noirs.
Je suis également demi-lakota, mais c'est bien mon vrai nom,
et non, bien qu'il pourrait sembler
que ç'aurait été un choix évident,
non, je n'ai pas fait de politique.
Vous êtes un public difficile...
(Rires)
Euh mais j'aime bien juste dire aux gens, pour qu'ils sachent,
lorsqu'ils posent des questions à propos de la race ou ce genre de choses,
vous savez, en tant que membre de la communauté des Premières Nations,
vous savez, je suis certainement
pas un « monsieur tout-le-monde ».
Par exemple, en plus d'être un activiste,
je suis aussi un comédien professionnel du stand-up
(Rires)
Et, vous savez, je suis très apprécié
dans les universités et les écoles post-secondaires.
Vous savez lorsqu'ils veulent faire une « journée de la diversité »,
ou une semaine « hey-on-n'est-pas-tous-blancs »,
je suis là ! (Rires)
Pensez-vous qu'il y aura un jour un monde post-racial ?
Je pense, en vérité, que je ne peux pas parler d'une race
sans me souvenir que c'est un idéal
dans un certain sens,
mais également, vous savez,
jusqu'à ce que l'on défasse les torts du passé
nous nous ferons manipuler.
Je me fiche de savoir si le présent est le nouveau futur.
Je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de gens biens ici, à TED
qu travaillent pour rectifier tout ça,
donc, sur ce, si quoi que ce soit que j'ai dit aujourd'hui
vous gêne, eh bien de rien !
(Applaudissements)
Je crois qu'on a assez de temps pour une dernière.
« Quel est le régime le plus populaire en ce moment ? »
Qui avons-nous là ?
Ok, bon, je vais juste répondre à celle-là très rapidement,
comme si j'étais trois ou quatre personnes différentes.
Je veux dire, très rapidement !
Je vais juste vous faire savoir que, en ce qui concerne les régimes,
si tu ne t'aimes pas en dedans,
il n'y a aucun régime sur cette Terre
qui pourra rendre ton derrière assez fin
pour que tu te sentes bien.
Alors arrête de gaspiller ton temps.
J'aimerais simplement dire que, en tant que femme africaine,
que je crois que le régime qu'il nous faut
est vraiment d'annihiler cette croyance ridicule
qu'il y a quoi que ce soit de mal
à avoir de belles fesses.
Non, je vous taquine avec ça.
Il n'y a rien de mal à être une femme imposante.
C'est ce que j'essaie de dire.
Les femmes, célébrez votre corps pour l'amour de Dieu !
Arrêtez de vous balader en mourant de faim !
Vous vous ruinez la vie, et celle des autres aussi !
Dernière réponse.
On parle bien du régime le plus populaire ?
je vais commencer par vous dire que
c'est ma première fois là, à TED.
je ne suis pas la « madame-tout-le-monde »
que vous verrez sur cette scène.
Mon attirail dentaire est pas aussi beau que certaines personnes.
Mais j'ai fait promettre à Sarah Jones
qu'elle m'emmènera cette fois !
parce qu'elle m'a pas emmenée avant.
Mais vous savez, je veux juste dire,
qu'il y a beaucoup de choses plus importantes
que de compter les calories.
Et comme je vis dans la rue à New York,
mais de pouvoir venir ici, toutes ces idées valent le coup d'être diffusées.
Je veux vous dire que je crois en cette idée
que le présent est le nouveau futur,
que là où vous vous asseyez, vous créez
tout ce qui va venir, pour le meilleur et pour le pire.
Et pour moi, je pense que « sans-abri »
n'est pas le bon mot pour le dire.
Vous savez, je n'ai peut-être pas d'endroit à moi
où poser ma tête la nuit,
mais ça fait simplement de moi une sans-maison.
J'ai un chez-moi. Et vous aussi.
Trouvez-le et essayez de vous y retrouver là-dedans.
Et vérifiez, vous savez,
que ce n'est pas une histoire de réalité virtuelle dans l'espace.
C'est merveilleux, mais c'est aussi une histoire
de réalité véritable ici, sur Terre.
Comment vivent les gens aujourd'hui ?
Comment pouvez-vous aider à y remédier ?
Merci à tous d'y penser
maintenant, dans l'instant présent,
afin d'influencer le futur.
Je l'apprécie. Bye bye.
(Applaudissements)
Merci à tous, merci vraiment beaucoup.
Merci de m'avoir fait confiance, Chris.
(Applaudissements)